Oh welcome to another scintillating
episode of what's in the box man I'm
r2d2 c-3po and here on this Death Star
all we do is dig into the trash
compactor pull out a one-eyed monster
and I got way too erotic to me but
that's what I thought up when I saw star
with yeah it's like that looks like my
wiener I see a word that makes Jason
Mewes very happy Warcraft your Warcraft
roster yes alright I'm in an absolute
[ __ ] loss what is this this is
Warcraft which is gonna be a movie soon
this is a game is it related to
Warhammer at all
no the Warhammer is a little different
Gorka Morka no iPhone he loves him some
Gorka morkul war on japan this isn't you
know big gaming and you can choose the
different characters be honest with his
chat I'm really touch and go when it
comes to swords and sorcery and [ __ ]
like I love my Game of Thrones don't get
me wrong I love me some Excalibur's my
13 nights and [ __ ] like that but when
you start getting into giant Eagles
that's when you're in The Hobbit country
jack specific Warcraft action figures
that's who makes these I saw this Tyler
man like this dude was talking big troll
dude he's under or people or who's in
there that's my world is dying
there is nothing to go back to seemed a
little bit like Avatar
maybe I'm way wrong I'm sure every gamer
on the plan is like [ __ ] you you fat
asian this is the most metal mallet on
the plane here that [ __ ] was it
documents : could you imagine if you saw
that I'd do that big [ __ ] anybody and
they just like he that the last thing
you see in life is that a skull of the
TEL have a mallet be like oh why didn't
I call my mother more and then you're
gone
Chavez fimble is playing Lothar oh not
the hill people people he's on Vikings
you watch bike they knew Ben Foster he's
playing this guy that's Ben Foster
alright man Clancy Brown he's playing
black head does an excellent Lex Luthor
I'm too modest to boast he was also goes
way back to to like buckaroo bono where
he tells the story of young buckaroo
banzai Nakuru becomes an eyewitness to
history i think this movie's gonna be
huge that tons of kids play it so I
think all the gamers are gonna want come
watch the movie the kids out there I
like I never imagined I'd see [ __ ]
Lothar mix it up with black and mother
really yes to see it on the big screen
this is like a Griffin right you know
it's part bird park lion it's just not
for me when this takes place it's not
for me and yet oddly enough I go apeshit
whenever the dragons appear hug hug and
Game of Thrones so it's a fine line you
know what I'm saying if it's got
feathers [ __ ] it if it's got scales
celebrated that's my philosophy this guy
clearly got the wizard thing going and
look up so you can look up his skirt you
got an upskirt shot right there
it's just feet this stuff look at the
Gandalf finger from the Lord of the
Rings when I was a boy they made from
the Ralph Bakshi cartoon Dan Gao
greetings Frodo
I'm the two big dudes I'm gonna fight
you on that at all be lovely for change
to be little different I
these guys this is what it's like to be
thin we control the world all of the
best things in life belong to us use
your mallet dude use your bow black hand
please help us low far Lenihan how you
can tell I just learned the name well
done it well look at this oh you get to
be one of these creepy characters I
don't think that's the line of dialogue
oh oh let's finally do now they're
getting right give him kids mallets all
right and of course the thing that every
kid wants to be handed and every parent
wants to hand them four goddamn hat
there we go look at that it hurts it's
hurt me before the battle even begins
the kids are silent [ __ ] a hole you be
that guy I'm used to people being like
you're a [ __ ] animal with a dirty
mouth well here's my man I can't even
like have it placed here look this [ __ ]
son I'm keeping it real
even if I all danger I still got long
phony Township I just want to hang out
in the hills and smoke my weed I'm in
living the part food sure drinks out in
the park you know me I'm like Shia
LeBouf when I'm in the part I don't
leave the party yeah don't look don't
call him by any other name
call me Shia LeBouf in the orc latex
mask I'm an orc right here yes
we got a doom hammer toy oh look at that
Doomhammer of course was what I called
my dick in high school we're gonna have
a battle here boys coming we present
Warcraft the movie in one act
starring Jane Sabo yeah
hey [ __ ] come or go get off my land
[ __ ] off [ __ ] I give up oh yeah we
conquered in how much you think you'd
pay for the 1999 one size fits all
there's no back to it but you could
finally be the orc you've always wanted
to be $49.99 oh yeah but you wouldn't
been able to get it
it's [ __ ] on me this [ __ ] mask is
left hair all over me if I go home like
this my wife's gonna be like who are you
[ __ ] if that position like nobody I
was wearing an orc mask and then she'd
be even more sad the Doomhammer this is
19 I have no 14 1499 doesn't it weigh
about a pound nothing that weighs a
pound is gonna cost 1499 the world of
toys it's got some girth it's got a
price tag $24.99
like that's [ __ ] on the piano oh my
god you you've got the mystical magic
yes
that's [ __ ] up got it 199 man the axe
of Durotan well I feel like this is even
sturdier and more powerful than that but
I'm just saying
so you think they'd go an extra five
bucks for the app yeah my kids are gonna
want that the axe more dirtier and
dirtier and dirtier that's our motto
here at Jack's Pacific this axe that's
called the betrayer of humanity I mean
mind you that's a badass [ __ ] name
for all that was what I want I'm gonna
call you that from now on you're the
betrayer of humanity yeah
he's got an axe what would you pay for
it
I would pay $4.99 but I would say $29.99
24:9 same prices the [ __ ] am i what
would you pay for these action for years
I actually figured I would say 90 no
$24.99 for each of them
what would you pay for lothar versus
black hand minifigures set alright comes
with Lothar of the hill people and his
Griffin I was right it is a Griffin and
black hand and his Frostwolf I was gonna
call him a direwolf but that's crossing
brands Frostwolf every one of these
[ __ ] got a 12 in it man why why
people think like what wolves metal or
something like that you want metal you
want an aggressive animal adoption it
should be like my stock see hey this is
naturally Grizz they breed him to go
into the holes and get badgers oh he can
go into little Griffin's Hall the old
doc Simon run jump up bite to Griffin's
testicles often and go in his butthole
rip his intestines out from the inside
you know not for nothing but that's
probably the best scene that's not in
Warcraft that sounded fantastic well
there it is folks boy we looked at a lot
of [ __ ] from the box that we don't even
know what this is man but good times
we're still had so that's where you
could say for Warcraft movies coming out
hopefully everybody likes them stuff
you're going to see it I may go see it
there it is you want to see this open
other boxes and [ __ ] like that pull a
lot more of indignity out of it just
like we did today right to the screen
junkies right here at this address
that's below us man if you have to
[ __ ] smash them over the head with a
dual hammer and let them know what you
want us to yank out of the box dead
until the next time I'm Kevin Smith
chasing you and what we pulled out of
the box this was badass
watch this that's what we pulled out of
the box [ __ ] there's a poached egg
style Bob strike back again Oh
you
[Music]